SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
JOCELYN: Hi.
Jocelyn here.
And today we're going to go over
fall 2009's final exam,
problem 10.
As always we're going to start
by reading the question.
You have 333 milliliters of
alkaline solution at a pH
equal to 9.9.
You wish to neutralize this
by reacting it with 222
milliliters of acid.
What must be the value of
the pH of the acid?
So first off let's write down
the information that was given
and the information that
he's asking for.
So we have 333 milliliters
of a solution
with pH equal to 9.9.
And he's asking you what must
the pH be if you want to put
in 222 milliliters in order to
completely neutralize that
basic solution.
And the key here
is to recognize
what neutralize means.
And a neutralization is when you
take acid, or protons, and
base and it reacts to
form water, thus
creating a neutral solution.
So the next step would probably
be to figure out how
much excess hydroxide we
have in this solution.
And then we can figure out how
much hydrogen we need to react
with that hydroxide and to
form water in order to
completely neutralize
this solution.
So first step is to
find out what our
concentration of OH minus is.
And we do that by remembering
a few things
about acid/base solutions.
Right?
We know that if you have the pH
plus the pOH it equals 14.
And this is from the equilibrium
constant of this
neutralization reaction.
And then we can figure out what
the pOH is because we're
given the pH of our
initial solution--
9.9--
and that equals 4.01.
Now using the definition of
pOH, which is that the pOH
equals the negative log of the
concentration of the OH minus,
we can rearrange that and
get that our OH minus
concentration equals 10
to the negative pOH.
Right?
Just using our log
rules there.
So this gives us that our
current concentration of the
hydroxide ion is 10 to
the negative 4.1.
That gives us the concentration
of the
hydroxide, but what we really
want to know, if we're going
to use our neutralization
reaction here, is we want to
know how many moles
of hydroxide we
have in that solution.
And we can just do that
with stoichiometry.
Right?
The concentration is
in moles per liter.
And we know--
so our moles hydroxide equals
our concentration, which is 10
to the negative 4.1
moles per liter.
Times--
if we want to get rid of that
liter unit we multiply it by
our volume, which is 333
milliliters, converting it
from milliliters to liters.
And this gives us 2.65 times 10
to the negative 5 moles of
OH minus in solution.
So that's just the first
step of this problem.
Now that we have the number of
moles of OH minus we need to
find the number of moles of H
plus necessary to react with
this excess hydroxide, and then
we will be able to find
the concentration of hydrogen,
or protons,
in that second solution.
So first off we're going to
look at our neutralization
reaction over here and realize
that it's a one-to-one
stoichiometric ratio.
That means in order to react
with 2.65 times 10 to the
negative 5 moles of hydroxide,
we need the same number of
moles of hydrogen.
So over here I'm going to say
that this also equals the
moles of H plus needed.
All right.
Now that we have our moles H
plus needed, we need to do the
same process here
but in reverse.
So first we need to find the
concentration of protons that
we have. So given that we want
to only have 222 milliliters
of this solution, right?
So we have--
and we just divide that by
our volume, 0.222 liters.
Right?
Because we divide by 1,000 to
convert from milliliters.
And that equals 1.19
times 10 to the
negative 4 moles per liter.
So this is another problem where
you could get the answer
but not actually be answering
the question.
Right?
Because this is the
concentration of protons that
we need, but now we need
to convert that to pH.
So moving over here we'll just
write the final steps.
We know the definition of pH
is the negative log of the
concentration.
And so because we know the
concentration of protons we
know that the--
we just need to plug this into
our calculator and we get our
answer, which is a pH of 3.92.
Put a box around that one
because it's our correct final
answer, and you'll
be good to go for
this part of the problem.
Now moving on to part b we are
asked, name the conjugate base
of each of the following.
So we'll just start
part b right here.
And the first thing to recognize
is what does a
conjugate base mean.
And in an acid/base pair, or
when you have a kind of
dissociation of an acid, in the
most simple terms we can
think about it just
losing a proton.
In the leftover molecule, that's
the conjugate base
right there.
So in this problem we're asked
if the molecule loses a
proton, what is the resulting
molecule?
Ion, basically.
So part i we have HPO4, and
that will dissociate to
hydrogen phosphate ion.
Simple enough.
This is your conjugate base.
So that's your answer
for part i.
Moving to part ii.
We have CH3NH3 plus.
So it's kind of like an ammonia
ion but not quite--
sorry, ammonium.
And we know that this
dissociates by losing a
hydrogen off of the nitrogen,
because that's where the
positive charge is.
It makes more sense there.
And we get--
sorry, keeping the same
order as above--
a proton plus.
And this would be your
conjugate base.
If you were a little bit
confused on this one it might
help to draw the Lewis
structure, and you would see
that the formal charge does
actually reside on nitrogen
and, therefore, it makes
sense that the nitrogen
would lose a proton.
In addition, if you think about
the ammonia/ammonium ion
relationship you know that you
have NH3 going to NH4.
And in this case we just have
one of the hydrogens replaced
with a methyl group, and so you
can make the analogy there
that, oh, the hydrogen
would come from the
nitrogen in that case.
All right.
So hopefully this was pretty
straightforward.
As long as you're comfortable
with what a conjugate base is
and what the dissociation
reactions look like for acids.
So now on part c we are asked
to classify each of the
following as a Lewis acid
or a Lewis base.
Now first we need to remember
what a Lewis acid and
a Lewis base are.
So if you remember from lecture
or in your reading, we
know that a Lewis acid is an
electron-pair acceptor and a
Lewis base is an electron-pair
donor.
These definitions are just a
little more general than the
classic proton acceptor
or proton donor.
The first part is asking us
about the cyanide ion.
And to kind of clarify it for
yourself and because we're
asked about Lewis acids and
bases, which are to deal with
electron pairs, it might
be helpful to
draw the Lewis structure.
So for this molecule a good
Lewis structure looks like
this, and it has a net
negative charge.
And you can see that we have a
couple of lone electron pairs
there that aren't involved
in bonding.
And because it has a net
negative charge you can
imagine that these electron
pairs would want to kind of
grab onto something else that's
a little bit more
electron positive.
And because of that we
know that this is
actually a Lewis base.
It acts as a base and would grab
something like a proton
and thus become more, I don't
know, stable in some cases.
All right.
Moving to part 2.
We are asked about water, which
is a molecule that we
deal a lot with in acid/base
chemistry.
Again, you might be able to
answer this right off the bat,
but we're going to look at
the Lewis structure here.
Water has two lone pairs.
So that means it could very
well act as a Lewis base.
Hopefully that makes a
little bit of sense.
Right?
Because these electrons can go
and grab something like a
proton and form the hydronium
ion with a positive charge,
thus acting as a Lewis base.
It's important to remember
that even though we're
creating an acid in the
hydronium ion, this water
molecule in converting to the
acid acts as a Lewis base.
However, we also know that water
can lose a hydrogen and
accepts those electrons to form
the hydroxide ion, and
thus acts as a Lewis acid.
So in the case of water either
Lewis acid or Lewis base was a
correct answer in this case.
Now moving on to part d.
We will go over here, I think.
I'm sorry.
d, not b.
Again, it's going to be
about acids and bases.
Consider the effect each of the
following substances has
on the ionization of the
weak base ammonia.
For each state whether the
substance, one, suppresses
ionization, two, enhances
ionization, or, three, has no
effect on the ionization
of ammonia.
In each instance give a reason
for your choice.
Going back to the first part of
this question we see that
it's asking us about the
ionization of ammonia.
A good place to start from here
would be to write down
the reaction, just so we have
that on our paper, in our
mind, ready to think about it.
So we have ammonia--
and aqueous means that
it's in water, right?
And that is reacting
with water to form
the ammonium ion--
sorry--
by adding a proton and
a hydroxide ion.
OK.
So this is the reaction
we're asked about.
Now we need to look at each of
the three substances listed
and decide how it affects
this ionization.
So number i, we have KOH.
Again, a good place to start
is to write what happens to
potassium hydroxide when
it goes into water.
And we know that KOH is
a strong base and will
dissociate into potassium
plus hydroxide.
So we see that it produces
hydroxide.
And this should indicate to
you that, well, it has the
same product as one of
the products of the
ionization of ammonia.
And if we remember back a
little bit before this
section, we know that if you
have the same ion in solution
it will definitely affect the
solubility, or ionization.
So that's one way to think about
it, is that I now have a
common ion effect that will,
because there's more hydroxide
in solution now, it will push
this reaction, this
equilibrium, back to the left.
Another way to think
about that is
Le Chatelier's Principle.
Kind of the same thing, although
it's a little bit
more versatile, I think, so
pretty easy to think about.
Right?
If you add a product
your reaction will
shift to the left.
If you add a reactant
your reaction will
shift to the right.
So here we're adding a product,
our reaction will
shift to the left.
Same as a common ion effect,
these two combine to decrease,
or both suggest that we will
decrease, ionization.
Moving to the second part
of this problem.
We're asked about hydrogen
chloride.
Again, let's look at what
that does in water.
We know that it's a strong acid,
so it will dissociate
into hydrogen, or protons,
and chloride.
Now this one's a little bit
trickier because we don't have
either of these ions in our
initial ionization reaction,
but if we think about the fact
that ammonia is a weak base we
can write an additional
ionization reaction.
So that additional would be
ammonia reacting with a proton
to form ammonium.
Right?
So this is another way
that the ammonia
molecule would be ionized.
And we can see that if we add
protons from this acidic
molecule there we will increase
the ionization,
because it will allow the
ammonia to work more as a base
because of this reaction here.
So we are increasing
ionization.
Another way to think about this
is completely valid and
kind of the same thing, but if
we look at this ionization
reaction here where the
hydrogen chloride is
dissociating into protons and
chlorides we can recognize
that these protons will then
react with the hydroxide that
is produced in the initial
ionization reaction.
This will result in a decrease
of hydroxide
in solution, right?
And so by Le Chatelier's
Principle we know that a
decrease in a product causes the
reaction to shift towards
the product, to make
more hydroxide.
So that's just another way of
thinking about the same
process, and it results in the
same conclusion that addition
of hydrogen chloride increases
the ionization of ammonia.
OK.
Moving to part iii.
We have ammonium chloride, and
this will dissociate into
ammonium and chloride.
And even if you're not sure how
much it will dissociate,
it will still dissociate
to some amount.
So it will have at least a
little bit of an effect on our
initial ionization reaction.
So here we see the dissociation
produces ammonium
ions, and just like the first
case that is one of the
products in our ionization
reaction.
And so Le Chatelier's Principle,
common ion effect,
whatever you want to call it,
tells us that it will shift
the equilibrium to the left
and decrease ionization.
So with that we're done with
problem 10 from the final.
It had a lot to do with
acid/bases, so hopefully you
feel more comfortable with
them after this.